كركوك المدينه الغنيه بالنفط لم تكن يوما
خارج دائره الصراع والحروب التي شهدتها
البلاد على مدى عقود متتاليه مئات المدارس
تضررت كحال هذه المدرسه بينما اتخذ بعضها
سكنات عسكريه للحركات المسلحه طبعا تاثر
الوضع حروب من الثمانين
[موسيقى]
التسعين للحصار الى 2003 دخول القوات
الامريكيه
2003 الى العراق واللي جرى ما جرى يعني
هذا بدا الارهاب ايضا
ولتعويض النقص في عدد المدارس واستيعاب
الاف الطلبه النازحين الى كركوك لجات
الحكومه المحليه الى اقامه هذه الفصول
الدراسيه المؤقته لكن المعاناه لم تنتهي
كل الشنعاني انه وضيق تنفس اكو بالصيف
وماكو تهويه وابدا بغير صالح يعني صراحه
للدراسه
قيمه هذه الفصول على عجل قبل سنوات من
الاخشاب والمواد الجاهزه كحل مؤقت الى حين
اصلاح المدارس المتضرره لكن يبدو ان هذه
الفصول التي تعاني مشكلات كثيره ستستمر في
الخدمه سنوات اخرى بالرغم من تاكيد
مسؤولين البدء في ازالتها بسبب كثره
النزوح لكركوك صار عندنا مدارس كرفانيه
حاله اضطراريه سويناها لكن حاليا بدينا
نزيلها تقول الحكومه العراقيه ان قله عدد
المدارس دفعت وزاره التربيه لجعل الدوام
فيها ثنائيا او ثلاثيا او حتى رباعيا وان
هناك
1500 مدرسه بحاجه الى الترميمات اضافه الى
1200 مدرسه مبنيه من الطين او القصب
ويبدو ان على هؤلاء الطلاب تحمل هذه
الظروف الصعبه الى حين داخل فصول دراسيه
يعبر حالها عن حال معظم قطاعات الحياه في
عموم العراق على الرغم من ان كركوك اشتهرت
بثروتها النفطيه فان تداعيات الحروب
والنزوح التي مرت على المدينه اثرت على
مختلف مناحي الحياه فيها ولم يكن القطاع
التربوي بمن انعم تلك التداعيات امير فندي
الجزيره كركوك